tu es né ici tu as grandi ici ce dôme
est le seul monde que tu as connu
[Musique]
il y a un endroit juste après la crête
est
c'est là papa je comprends pas de quoi
tu parles tu verras
tu iras
à
je sais pas ce qu'il y a là-bas mais ton
père voulait que tu le vois on n'est
jamais sorti du dôme
qu'est-ce qui est décidé on part ce soir
il paraît qu'elle est bizarre pourquoi
et alors son bizarre toi aussi tu es
bizarre tout le monde est d'accord
on va voler à Rover
le confinement va commencer par 5 4 3 2
tu sais ce qui est super dans les virées
c'est que tu laisses vraiment tout
derrière toi
[Musique]
et maintenant fin de la 9e manche je
vais lancer la balle
[Musique]
le ciel sur la terre est-ce qu'il est
vraiment bleu
et souviens-toi le plus important c'est
une très mauvaise idée
ce n'est pas seulement de savoir où on
va
la plume météorite
mais comment on y va
les gens avec qui on parle
bientôt le savoir allez-y en premier
on n'est jamais tout à fait le même que
celui qu'on était au départ c'était les
deux plus beaux jours de ma vie
[Musique]